und da oben in die
tablinung hallo Jasper grüß Dich hi
kennst du unsere erste Frage nee meine
erste Frage nee ich bin ganz offen aber
du hast es dir schon mal angeguckt ich
hab es mir schon mal angeguckt aber die
erste ist meistens wie ist die Lage die
Lage ist gut ich bin bald unterwegs mit
meinen Liedern und habe gerade ein
zweites Album veröffentlicht und
durchaus alles in Ordnung gerade ist
gerade rausgekommen das Album V paar
Tagen genau wie lange hast Du daan
gesessen wie lange sitzt man an so einem
Album
recht viel Zeit gelassen eigentlich
insgesamt über über einen Monat 40 Tage
das ist schon
ganz ganz ordentlich eigentlich gewesen
wirklich nur im Studio zu sitzen nicht
nur am Stück aber eben 40 Tage nur
Studioarbeit und der Zeitraum von den
beiden Alben ist aber sehr dicht
aufeinander gewesen 10 Monate zwischen
zwei Alben das heißt
40 Tage das ist produziert worden aber
komponiert hast du schon vorher
ja die meisten die meisten Lieder waren
wirklich komplett fertig dann auch
manchmal hat man noch so ein paar
Kleinigkeiten wo da noch dran gearbeitet
wird wenn man ein bisschen eine Strophe
fehlt man da nicht so zufrieden mit ist
aber das große Gerüst das stand auf
jeden Fall schon dann ja beim ersten
Album war es aber so da hast du einfach
das genommen was schon da war jetzt beim
zweiten Album war es ja wirklich so du
hattest schon Plattenvertrag es stand
ein neues Album an das heißt es war ein
bisschen andere Situation richtig aber
ich war jetzt auch nicht in der
Situation dass ich so einen großen Druck
hatte jetzt was was zu produzieren und
dass die Plattenfirma jetzt gesagt hätte
e wir brauchen unbedingt noch so ein
Lied und hier und da muss noch ein
Liebeslied hin und sonst wird das nichts
das war nicht der Fall ich bin einfach
auch in der Zeit danach ja recht
produktiv gewesen und habe weiter dran
gearbeitet und insofern war das war das
keine Schwierigkeit da dann noch mal ein
Album zustande zu bringen wir haben dich
jetzt klassisch wie man sich so für ein
singer songriter vorstellt am Bahnhof
als zugreisend abgeholt mit
Gitarre ja das Bild das hatte ich schon
so im Kopf ich musste ja mit der Bahn
reisen ihr wolltet das ja so ich wollte
das gar nicht Platten wollte das aber
warst du in dieser Rolle warst du da
schon vorher oder hat sich das durch
diesen Youtube Hype erst ergeben dass du
sagtest gut dann bin ich jetzt halt
singer Song weiter weil du hast ja auch
andere Interessen Theater
Schauspielen wie ist das entstanden oder
in welcher Situation bist du jetzt da ja
also ich mache das jetzt wirklich
hauptsächlich gerade nur das das lieders
Schreiben und eben die Musik es ist
schon so dass ich dass ich gerne in
dieser Rolle bin also singer songwriter
finde ich super wobeil ich es halt ein
bisschen schwierig finde den Begriff
auch auch an sich dafür Zug gebrauchen
ich mag den Begriff sehr gerne aber es
ist ja doch irgendwie deutschsprachige
Musik und dann weiß ich nicht ist das so
treffend das mit singer songriter Sänger
Liedschreiber ja im Prinzip müsste man
so weiß ich auch nicht wir hatten auch
mal als Arbeitsziel so Liedermacher 2.0
um auch das das Internet da wieder ein
bisschen mit aufzugreifen und das ist
für mich super dass es so gelaufen ist
ich mach's wirklich gerne ja hast du dir
die Rolle ausgesucht weil der HDL Song
war ja erstmal du hast ja gar nicht
damit gerechnet dass das so ein Hype
wird sondern es war mehr so wie viele
viele viele andere you yoube User die
sagen hier ich mache Musik und meine
Freunde können mal gucken und aber das
sowas draus entsteht war ja überhaupt
nicht mit zurechnen ja schon ein
bisschen verrückte Sache also hätte ich
wirklich nicht mit gerechnet aber es ist
ja nicht so dass ich jetzt gezwungen
werde Lieder zu schreiben ich mache das
einfach wahnsinnig gerne und habe jetzt
die Chance damit einfach viele Leute zu
erreichen eben auch außerhalb des
Internets mit den den Clubtouren mit
anderen Konzerten oder eben auch mit mit
den CD Veröffentlichung das ist eine
super Sache sofern bin ich da nicht in
der Rolle reingedrängt sondern kann
meinen Ding weiter machen aber eben
öffentlich ja aber ich sag mal
reingerutscht in die Rolle weil es hätte
ja sein können vor zwei Jahren dass du
sagst auch komm ich leg jetzt den
Schwerpunkt auf Theaterspiel z.B ja das
schon das ist im Prinzip schon so
gewesen dass ich da reingerutscht bin
und also gerne gerutscht bin aber ich
habe es nicht drauf angelegt das jetzt
so als Weg zu zu sehen es hat sich
ergeben ja fühlst du dich wohl in deiner
Haut und zwar nicht nur in dem Sinne
dass es dir Spaß macht auf der Bühne zu
sitzen sondern auch in dem Sinne dass du
denkst hm das ist auch eine Perspektive
da werde ich vielleicht dauerhaft von
leben können oder bist du noch unsicher
und denkst hm vielleicht hätte ich auch
das andere machen sollen also ich gehe
da e ziemlich realistisch dran und mach
das jetzt gerade weil es weil es mir
Spaß macht weil es gut läuft aber nicht
so mit Scheuklappen irgendwie vor den
Augen ich sag
das ist jetzt das was ich was ich ewig
mache und ich mache nur das ich denke
schon dass ich mich auch noch anders da
orientieren werde für im studiumsmäßig
äh zu gucken was was man sonst noch
machen kann aber die Musik möchte ich
auf jeden Fall weitermachen und das kann
man auch gut es gibt viele Leute die das
auch gut parallel hinbekommen aber
gerade den Start den da konzentriere ich
mich jetzt schon voll drauf das äh
selbst mitzumachen um eben auch in ja
den verschiedenen Bereichen die noch so
mit dabei sind äh selber ja drin zu
stecken ob das jetzt layoutarbeiten sind
oder konzertvorbereitungen sind äh das
möchte ich mir ganz ungne nur aus der
Hand nehmen lassen und investiere
einfach jetzt sehr viel Zeit in
unterschiedliche Bereiche das heißt du
nimmst das wie so Ausbildung eine singer
Song weiter Ausbildung qu ja wo du alles
das lernt was ja ich nehme das auf jeden
Fall mit also nehme auf jeden Fall sehr
viel mit an Möglichkeiten die es da gibt
um trotzdem meiner Linie da auch treu zu
bleiben und mich nicht irgendwie da
jetzt verheizen zu lassen also da habe
ich schon dadurch dass ich da sehr
kritisch auch angegangen bin einen ganz
guten Überblick was was so geht und was
was ich nicht machen möchte und denke da
bin ich auf dem ganz guten Weg da
realistisch irgendwie dranzugehen freue
mich dass es gerade gut läuft aber
natürlich geht's immer weiter und
vielleicht schraubt man auch ab und zu
dann seine Ansprüche ein bisschen höher
aber bis jetzt
bin ich echt zufrieden mit dem wie es
läuft ist denn das
Musikgeschäft nicht vielleicht für so
eine Einstellung zu sehr Musikgeschäft
oder geht das ich versuch da mal ein
bisschen Akzente zu setzen nee also ich
ich bin auch selber erstaunt muss ich
sagen ich bin ich bin erstaunt dass ich
auch ein Plattenvertrag bei einem recht
großen Label jaah bekommen habe aber
dass sie wirklich das auch total
unterstützen dass sie mich nicht
irgendwo hin pushen und das sage ich
jetzt nicht irgendwie nur so damit das
rüberkt es ist wirklich so ist ein super
nettes Team mit dem ich zusammenarbeite
und wenn ich irgendwelche Fragen habe
dann wird sofort telefoniert und wir
klären da was und es ist nicht so die
die die böse Plattenfirma Haut jetzt
drauf und pusht den dahin in bestimmten
Bereichen ist es sicherlich so aber dann
also meine ich ist es so dass das dass
man dafür irgendwie härter drauf sein
muss oder mehr noch nach vorne pushen
muss z ja z.B aber das sind halt
Bereiche wo man mich nicht reindrängt
und wo ich mich auch nicht reindrängen
lassen würde wie kommt es dass eine
große Plattenfirma Major Label dann mit
so jemanden Vertrag macht hast du damit
gerechnet weil du hattest ja dieses
erste so Sympathie Punkte äh das war das
war einfach eine sehr interessante Sache
ich kann das kurz erzählen wie das
angefangen hat ich habe wie gesagt ein
paar Lieder ja reingestellt bei Youtube
und über diesen HDL Song der sich mit
den chatabkürzungen beschäftigt das sind
dann einige Leute drauf aufmerksam
geworden und eben auch zwei Musiker die
auch als Produzenten tätig sind und die
haben mich dann kontaktiert und
angefragt wollen wir was machen
in der Zeit kamen schon ein paar andere
Anfragen also auch so z.B der kleine
Kevin der dann gefragt hat hey mein
großer Bruder der ist 17 der wird gerne
dein Management übernehmen und wo man
dann schon ein bisschen überlegt mal
abwarten vielleicht kommt ja noch was
anderes äh und mit den beiden Musiker
Produzenten habe ich mich dann getroffen
und es ist ein sehr nettes Team was der
Zusammenarbeit schon einige Sachen
zusammen gemacht haben und
mit denen habe ich dann das das erste
Album aufgenommen also ohne
Plattenvertrag unüblich ist es ist aber
jetzt noch mal anzufangen mit Demos fand
ich auch irgendwie komisch denn das die
sind im Netz habe ich die Lieder schon
mal dargestellt man kann immer na
plattenfirmer zeigen guck mal hier so
sieht das auch aus und ich hatte einfach
schon recht klare Vorstellung was ich
auch dann machen wollte und hatte genug
Material und dann haben wir
zusammengesetzt geguckt hier daraus
machen wir ein Album die Lieder wählen
wir aus und haben wirklich dann ein
komplettes Album
gemacht und das dann verschiedenen
Labels Angeboten ich hatte mir auch noch
die Option gelassen das selber
rauszubringen aber das ist mir dann doch
eine Nummer zu groß geworden und ich bin
auch sehr froh dass ich das nicht so
gemacht habe
und ja dann hat hat die die major Firma
gesagt ja möchten wir Sony Music möchten
wir gerne machen und das komplette Album
wird dann so
rausgebracht das ist aber wahrscheinlich
auch für Sony Music das erste Mal
gewesen dass sie gesagt hat das weiß ich
nicht aber es ist es ist wirklich toll
also ja selten und ich weiß seh zu
schätzen glaube ich ich habe natürlich
da auch noch nicht so viel Erfahrung
dass ich äh groß Vergleiche hätte wie
wie läuft das aber was man so mitkriegt
ist natürlich schon eher so du du machst
Demos und schickst die irgendwo hin und
kriegst dann absagen und bist enttäuscht
und ich hatte halt alles irgendwie ohne
so ein Zwang auch ohne große Perspektive
ich hatte auch das Album nicht
produziert mit dem Hintergedanken das
muss ein Major Deal werden ne es ist
alles kam schon alles so zusammen und
auch gerade weil ich es nicht erwartet
habe äh es ist ist ein sehr großes Glück
auch so gewesen gab's denn nicht doch
ein Moment wo du dann Überflieger
gekriegt hast so äh so
Moment ging ne echt nicht gab's nicht
mal so ein Tag mensch Leute also wenn
Youtube Star major Deal hey leute wo wer
sind die anderen hier bin ich also ich
mag ich mag z.B auch diesen diesen
Begriff Youtube Star ihr hab mich auch
so angekündigt ne den den mag ich selber
auch würde ich jetzt selber mir jetzt
nicht geben ich meine ne Millionen
Klicks insgesamt ist natürlich eine
coole Sache
was auch nicht jeder irgendwie schafft
mit seinen Videos ich mehr als die ARD
ich glaube auch mehr alsdf da stecken
sicherlich nicht 9 Millionen Menschen
dahinter ne sind ein paar die haben
einfach mal kurz aufgerufen und sind
dann wieder weg dann gibt's welche die
haben sich vielleicht ein Lied 20 mal
angeguckt aber trotzdem bin ich froh
dass ich das mit eigener Musik geschafft
habe und mit ja mit eigenen Sachen und
das ist vielleicht das wo ich ein
bisschen stolz dann auch drauf bin ähm
und jetzt jetzt nicht es gibt so viele
Videos wo es wo es um Schadenfreude geht
wo was weiß ich wenn ich jetzt meinen
Hamster getastet hätte und das hätten 5
Millionen Leute
aufgerufen wäre ich nicht so stolz
irendwie dann gewesen und so ist es halt
wirklich für mich auch eine gute Sache
gewesen und wenn ich jetzt Konzerte habe
dann bin ich natürlich danach auch ein
bisschen beflügelt und freue mich wenn
es den Leuten gefallen hat aber ich habe
gesetzten und und beständigen
Freundeskreis die die Familie hält ein
gibt einem Rückhalt aber hält einen auch
durchaus mal zurück wenn wenn man
irgendwie so beim Frühstückstisch
vielleicht dann doch mal den anf
einschein kriegt jetzt komm macht mal
alles ne hast du den Anflug dann doch
hat du nicht oder hast du immer übergt
was wäre wenn rechtzeitig gebremst nee
also keine keine großen Ausbrüche
wirklich nicht nee ich nehme jetzt mal
den abgedroschenen begriff was macht
dich so bodenständig ist es Emden m ich
glaube das hängt damit zusammen dass
sich vieles auch noch im Internet
abspielt und man da noch auf einer
anderen
Ebene vielleicht auch kommuniziert doch
ich habe nicht wahnsinnig viele
fernsehtermine ich habe nicht ständig
Leute um mich herum schwirren ich mach
teilweise die Videos ja auch dann
irgendwie von von zu Hause oder oder
mach t für
Telefonate und das sind glaube ich auch
Dinge die einen da ein bisschen
zurückhalten dass man nicht ständig
irgendwie Leute um sich herum hat die
einem erzählen wie toll das doch alles
ist also im Internet ja schon da das
funktioniert ähm aber auch gut dass ich
da ein gewissen Abstand zu bekomme und
äh ja mir einfach auch klar mache ähm
das gefällt den Leuten aber wenn es mir
schlecht geht klicke ich jetzt nicht die
ganzen Kommentare durch na geht mir doch
eigentlich ganz gut irwi das mache ich
dann nicht was sagen denn deine Freunde
sind die nicht auch so ein bisschen
Berater das kommt das kommt drauf an um
was es für Bereiche geht ne wenn es
jetzt irgendwie darum geht Verhandlungen
zu machen meint ihr das ist sind
irgendwie genug Prozente die ich da
bekomme oder da kann dir kein Freund der
nicht in der Materie drin ist helfen ne
aber
trotzdem ist es mir natürlich wichtig
die Leute auch ein bisschen mitzunehmen
auf den Weg zu erzählen was ich so mache
mit was ich mich gerade beschäftige und
sag auch hier ihr müsst auch mal zum
Konzert kommen und das mal angucken klar
also der Austausch ist auf jeden Fall da
haben die das überhaupt mitgekriegt
eigentlich meine Freundin haben das
schon mitgekriegt ja ja es gibt ja of
dass man sowas
äh dass man das dass das so nebenleben
ist man ist im Freundeskreis und mit den
geht man halt ins Kino macht dies mach
das aber die kriegen gar nicht mit dass
man woanders äh äh ich meine man macht
natürlich andere Sachen mit den ja klar
man geht ins Kino aber die Wissen
trotzdem dass ich vielleicht nächste
Woche da und da ein Auftritt habe aber
also die wissen schon darüber Bescheid
dann ähm anderes Thema Freundinn und
zwar fällt es dir jetzt leichter oder
ist es eher eine Behinderung bekannt zu
sein ähm eine Behinderung würde ich
nicht sagen aber ich würde jetzt also
ich habe momentan keine Freundin und
kein Freund
die ja ich bin momentan nicht auf der
Suche nach einer Freundin und auch
keinem Freund weil das ja immer auch die
Frage ist ne ja genau aber du hast nicht
beantwortet ja ich suche dann eher eine
Freundin aber bin gerade nicht auf der
auf der Suche warum bist du nicht auf
der Suche wenn du solo bist ja das ist
halt das ist halt das Ding dass ich
lieber ja abwarte was aber das würde ich
auch gerne mit der Musik eben verknüpfen
natürlich ist da bekommt man da auch
dann Post übers übers
Internet manchmal dann auch von der
sichrigen Mama die dann irgendwie ir
Liebesbrief schreibt nee keine Ahnung
aber ja so in der Form jetzt nicht aber
so ähnlich so ähnlich äh aber ich würde
da nicht irgendwie die Internetpräsenz
ausnutzen für sowas ja denke man mussen
Menschen dann auch anders kennenlernen
und die Möglichkeit kann ich den Leuten
die es übers Internet sich das angucken
oder die CD kaufen kann ich nicht bieten
und möchte ich auch nicht das ist also
auch für mich eine klare Grenze wo ich
sag nee
ich verteile jetzt nicht hier meine ICQ
Nummer und möchte mit jedem irgendwie
Kontakt haben das kannst du nicht machen
und das hat auch was unwirkliches
einfach denn das Interesse muss auf
jeden Fall immer von beiden Seiten da
sein ist es aber vielleicht für
eine potenzielle Freundin leichter Dich
kennenzulernen weil sie deine Texte weil
sie dich schon ein bisschen kennenlernt
über die
Musik weiß ich nicht also man muss
hinter auf jeden Fall gleich Interessen
haben das ist mir sehr wichtig also die
sollte schon auch Interesse an der
Sprache eben haben und
äh ja also eine gemeinsame Basis ist
einfach wichtig ne und die muss vorher
nicht die Musik kennen sollte schon
irgendwie ein bisschen Interesse dran
haben sonst wird das glaube ich auch mit
so ein Leben auch ein bisschen schwierig
er macht wieder Musik wieder Musik komm
lass die Gitarre stecken aber
ja eine gemeinsame Basis hat ja
unterschiedliche unterschiedliche
Aspekte einfach gibt eigentlich ein Song
über das Thema bei dir auf
ohenpost über über Thema Liebe
kennenlernen auf der ohrenpost
ein bisschen trauriges Ende lautlos ist
ist ein Lied da geht es darum dass ein
Junge unter das Fenster seiner
Angebeteten tritt und als Minnesänger
quasi als Minnesänger und ihr seine
Liebe gesteht geht aber ein bisschen
traurig aus sind zweiten oder dritten
Hören nee ich ma das ohne Gitarre das
ist ja ja dann wünsche ich dir viel
Erfolg beim nicht suchen einer Freundin
und beim Finden beim finden damit wirst
du sie finden ich bin zeugt vielen Dank
gerne